[Music]
longing to be google
ah
ribéry pepe garza
[Music]
and work until scam
so that about
efe I
walk
with
efe
another week more interest
[Music]
for infections
contacts molar
my hand
[Music]  ]
[Applause]
[Music] I
tremble
now
is that I
[Music]
[Applause]
a
is
[Music]
[Applause]
why
and today nuclear de facto
kurt von trier who had created me
today  stoner oro
low
[Music]
on your website
look at me here I
should use
[Applause]
time chronicle
but
I don't know
and well
oh
or not
[Music]
like in a car that with schumacher
efe
god me
and you org
efe that got stuck
garden that still  the wood was stronger
the duties
were the son
you are the one who controls
or stop them I never loved you respect
we have arrived from jail
benítez the bayern
louis and we reported
racing
[Music]
those scandals
don't have
tea
not
at all
one  good time
makes us
or
[Music]
not
even  to have fun
[Music]
on Friday
and
[Music]
on the street
next is to control the best of
expression
no